[Music] Honestly,
on a personal level, on the day of the earthquake, I had a
vacation. The days of vacation were on the
scene sets. The cadres were requested.
All the cadres went to the hospital, so I
responded to the order. The work started from Monday, the
morning of the earthquake, and until today, 6 days, seven days.
I am in the hospital on shift 4 for a
period of time.  24 hours a day. We enter the operating rooms
from eight or nine in the morning until
2:00 at night, between patients and in the operating rooms
[music].
In many cases, it was very touching. I mean, one of the cases was a
three-month-old child who lost his
entire family. He was still the only survivor, the
only survivor of the family.  His health condition was
very critical. He was on a ventilator and
had multiple injuries in the chest, abdomen,
and head
[music].